RICHARD KARLGAARD: Thanks,
I am with "Forbes."
I've been with "Forbes"
since the early '90s.
In fact, I joined "Forbes."
Steve Forbes hired me to
start a technology magazine,
and one of my go-to
people, whenever
I needed understand this
new thing called the web,
was a guy who ran R&D at
Sun Microsystems named
Eric Schmidt.
So Eric was always-- Eric was
always a tremendous friend
and helped me understand
what was emerging
in the future of network
computing more than just
about anyone.
Now I live in Silicon Valley, as
does my co-author Mike Malone.
And one day, we were
sitting around noting
how many great startups
in Silicon Valley
had been done by pairs,
trios, or quartets--
from Hewlett Packard, to
Apple, Steve Wozniak and Steve
Jobs, Sergey Brin and Larry
Page, the Paypal mafia.
I mean, over and over again,
you see the same story
repeating of very small
teams-- two, three, four,
five-- starting these
tremendous enterprises.
And so we proposed
to a publisher
to write a book about that.
The publisher wisely
came back and said, well,
that'll just be storytelling.
Can you find some science
and data behind this?
And can you apply it to
large organizations as well?
So that's what we set out to do.
And Team Genius-- really, we
looked at what neuroscience,
anthropology, cognition
science, and so on and so forth,
has to say about why it is
that some small teams thrive
and others don't.
You've all probably
been on teams
where everything
looked good on paper.
You had the right set of
skills, and something somehow it
didn't gel.
And then you've
probably been on teams
where everybody on the
team was a pain in the ass
that you were
fighting all the time.
It seemed like it was always
on the verge of fragmenting,
and somehow the team
produced great work.
Now, our theory is that all
the great work in the world
is going to be done by small,
informal teams going forward.
That is the startup
model of small teams.
It's one that is going to apply
in large organizations too.
And the reason is that the
world to simply moving too fast.
Google has 55,000 employees,
but every now and then,
a company will come up like
Snapchat with 19 employees,
and seemingly they're
able to do things
in an extraordinarily
short period of time.
And why is that?
The world is moving too fast.
So the theory that we
have in Team Genius
is that inside of
large organizations,
if you're really going
to get work done,
you have to create
an organization
where teams of 2 to 12 people,
just like the startup world
does naturally, inside
of larger organizations,
teams of 2 to 12 people
can spontaneously
arise to meet a challenge
or to pursue an opportunity.
Here's the
mathematical reason why
small teams work and big
teams fall apart very quickly.
That equation, you probably
know, is Metcalfe's Law,
but it shows just how fast
the number of connections
rise when you add people.
And so if you have
two team members,
you have one connection.
If you have 12 team members, you
have 66 possible connections.
And the reason that 12 starts
breaking down, after 12,
is that the number
of connections
go up almost exponentially.
16 team members--
120 connections.
32-- 496.
So things become
unwieldy very quickly.
What breaks in a breakpoint?
Well, communications,
accountability, and trust
begin to break down very
rapidly when you get over 12.
You start getting the
phenomenon of free riders.
That is people-- I'm sure
this doesn't happen at Google,
But it happens in
every organization
I've been involved
with that is large.
If a project looks
hot and successful,
people want to join in.
Everybody wants to be
part of the success.
Then they may not do
the work, but they
want to have it on
their resume, and they
want to be able to
take credit for it.
Conversely, when
things get challenging,
those kind of people will bail,
will start pointing fingers
and become politicians.
Exactly the kind
of thing that you
don't want in any kind of a
team where you have high stakes
and you need to accomplish
stuff in a hurry.
Here's what we found
out, the research.
And these researchers
are cited in the book.
One is a neuroscientist.
One is an anthropologist.
One is a social psychologist.
And that is the optimal
size of creative teams.
Remember, I said 2 to 12
is sort of a good range
of creative strike teams.
And amazingly,
within that range,
things begin to tighten up.
These three researchers
from different fields
have used numbers like
7, 5 to 7, and 4 to 9.
I like 4 to 9.
I call it 7 plus or minus 2.
And the book goes into why teams
of that size, whether you're
talking about musical bands,
artistic groups, software
projects, marketing launches,
PR launches-- whatever
it is, this is an optimal size.
And there are reasons why
the brain prefers that size.
In fact, the size of seven
as a phone number-- the phone
company didn't come up with the
size seven for a phone number
accidentally.
It turns out that that's
the median of short term
memory for people.
Software people obviously have
super short term memories,
which means that there
are a lot of people
walking around that have
crappy short term memories.
But seven is the median for
the vast majority of people,
and that's why,
again, it accords
to the people you can hold
in your brain and the ideas
that you can hold in your
brain as you're walking around.
Well, Google has
55,000 employees.
Does this still apply?
I'm going to make
the argument that it
makes no difference what the
size of the organization is.
That it's the task
of Google to be able,
to out of 55,000 people, all
of whom are super bright.
This friend of mine likes
to say to work at Google,
you have to have an
IQ that boils water.
But even inside
that 55,000 people,
unless you can spontaneously
get to these smaller sizes,
projects get bogged down.
The Snapchats of the world
with a tiny number of people
can pop up.
And while you're trying to
organize teams from on high,
Snapchat has developed
tens of millions of users.
That's why doing things
on a startup level
becomes so important.
Now, one of things we
wanted to do in the book
was take on some of the
more controversial areas
and see what research
had to say about that.
One of them is diversity,
specifically ethnic and gender
diversity.
And the research says that
it's a double edged sword,
that there's a much higher beta
when you have a diverse team
than when you have a team that
is monolithic, that everybody
looks the same, everybody
has the same color skin,
everybody has the same gender.
By higher beta, I mean
that a truly diverse team
has a higher probability of
creating extraordinary success.
And it also has a higher
probability of blowing up.
Now, if you're a global
company, we are at Forbes.
Google is.
Anybody that
touches the internet
is by definition a
global company today.
You have to take the risk.
If you're maybe a local
construction company,
and you're not touched
by the global economy,
perhaps you can have
a very monolithic team
and it will work.
But in a global
economy, anything
that's creative, the research
is very strong about this
that you have to,
whether you're doing it
for good reasons
of social justice
or whether you
want to accomplish
big things in a
global economy, you
have to take the risk
of being diverse.
The way that you
protect the downside-- I
said it has a higher beta.
You have a greater probability
of accomplishing great things,
but you also have a
greater probability
of having the team blow up.
The way that you prevent
the team from blowing up
is with strong leadership
and the right framing.
And I'm going to talk a
little bit about framing
in the next slide.
So here's the framing quiz.
Which of the following framing
strategies-- and remember,
this is back on the
topic of diversity.
And you're a leader of
a highly diverse team.
You have different ethnicities.
You're balanced in gender.
Which of the following
three framing strategies
produces the best results?
And this is according to Harvard
researchers Robin Eli and David
Thomas.
OK.
Number one, you have
three choices here--
integration and
learning perspective,
diversity as a mechanism
for helping teams enhance
their capacity for adaptive
change, your differences
and experience will
help us react quickly
to a rapidly
changing marketplace.
Now choice number two,
remember you're the leader.
You're trying to frame.
You're trying to
get the best out
of everybody in a
highly diverse team.
Number two, you frame it as
diversity is a better way
to connect with an increasingly
diverse marketplace.
Your differences and
cultural backgrounds
will help us understand
the global marketplace.
That's choice number two.
And now choice number three,
discrimination and fairness
perspective.
Diversity as a means to ensuring
fair equal treatment of all.
Our differences
ensure that there
will be no bias against anyone.
Who thinks the
optimal is number one?
If you recall it.
Who thinks the
optimal is number two?
And that's diversity because
the marketplace is diverse,
therefore we should be diverse.
And who thinks
it's number three?
OK.
The winner is the first one.
The integration and learning
experience perspective.
And that is using diversity
to make everybody smarter
on the team.
Discrimination and
fairness perspective-- eh.
Mixed results.
A lot of evidence suggests
that for all the inclusion
you might create with
that kind of perspective,
it also feels patronizing
to many people.
And surprisingly, the loser
is the access legitimacy
perspective.
It simply doesn't work,
according to these two Harvard
researchers.
Here's a huge one.
If you take away two
ideas from the book,
the two ideas that are the
major work in the world
is getting done by
teams of 2 to 12 people.
And that works
fine for startups,
because they are 2 to 12 people.
But if you have 55,000
people, you still
have to create
these organizations
where teams of 2 to
12 will spring up
spontaneously to solve a
problem or to meet a customer
opportunity.
If the team creation is
being ordered from on high,
you simply won't be
moving fast enough
to meet the challenges today.
That's idea number one.
The second idea is the power
of cognitive diversity.
And that is creating what
Tony Fidel, Tony Fidel,
of course, the guy who created
Nest Labs, and you guys
bought him in April, 2014.
Tony also is known as one of the
founders of the iPod, Apple's
breakout product.
Jonathan Rubinstein, Steve
Jobs, Tony Fidel did that.
And Tony, when I interviewed
Tony for a previous book--
Google is a very
algorithmic company.
And when Tony was designing
the smart thermostat,
he explained how it
worked, a thermostat that
learns your habits.
And he said, is that
an algorithmic problem
or is that a sociology problem?
Is it just simply observing
how people behave?
And he said it's both.
He said the problem is the
algorithmic people alone
will come up with one solution.
The non-algorithmic people will
come up with another solution.
And neither of them are
really great solutions
in and of themselves.
So what Tony always
tried to do, and I
think what great
companies do, Google
does this exceptionally
well-- is mash up what
he calls whole brain teams.
And that is within
these small teams,
you want to make sure that you
have left brain and right brain
thinkers.
You want introverts
and extroverts.
There's a great book by a
woman named Susan Cain called
"The Power of Quiet."
And it's really the power of
introverts in an organization.
Introverts are often very
underestimated inside
of an organization because
they don't speak up.
Risk IQ.
Everybody talks about risk
today and the importance
of being a risk
taking organization.
You actually want, in a
composition of a team,
you want conformists too.
You want the risk takers
to be about 25 to 20%
of the composition of the team.
You want the conformists
to be about half,
and you want the
rest of the people
to be strictly hard
focused operations people.
The reason you want
the conformists
is that the risk people
will be passionate for sure,
but they will run off the rails
if left to their own devices
as many times as not
more times than not.
And so the value of
conformance, even
at a highly evolutionary company
like Google, is very valuable.
You want tenure diversity.
That is to say, you
want experienced people
who can see all the
traps going forward
on a project, all the
political landmines,
all of the things that
can trip up a project.
But you also want
the fresh eyes,
because the problem
is with having
a lot a tenure is the "been
there, done that" cynicism
that begins to
creep in over time.
Now I briefly want to talk
about-- this alludes to a book
that I had last year.
And the two go together.
The book I had last year
was called "The Soft Edge."
My proposition
here is everything
I've talked about won't
happen in a culture
where you don't have trust.
This is one of things that
Satya Nadella's discovered
at Microsoft, is that the
Ballmer culture was so hard
wired for measurable results.
And the way
employees were ranked
within Microsoft, a
forced ranking system,
that, in fact, the
knives came out,
particularly the
top two quintiles.
If you're in the top
quintiles at Microsoft,
all the raises and all the
bonuses went to the people
in the top quintile.
People in the second quintile
got to keep their jobs.
People in the third, fourth,
and fifth-- the fifth forget it.
Third and fourth were kind
of on the bubble about
whether they'd be able
to keep their job.
But all the knives and
all the political wars
came out at the borderline
between the top quintile
and the second quintile,
because all the raises, and all
the accolades, and
all the promotions
went to people in
the top quintile.
So the trust was shattered.
When I was doing the
research on that book
to figure out what it is that
creates a healthy culture
inside of a company,
I googled health.
And if you google health, this
is one of the top three things
that you will get when you
google the word health.
It's this thing called
the United Nations
Triangle of Health.
This is what the
UN gives to doctors
who go into impoverished
areas of the world,
Doctors Without Borders,
organizations like that.
People who need to see
1,000 patients in a week.
If you're seeing 1,000 patients
in a week, all you can do
is triage, and this is the
tool to help you triage.
You look at somebody,
and in five minutes,
you try to determine
whether it's
physically healthy,
mentally healthy,
and have social health, which
means when they go home,
is there violence in their
families or lawlessness
in their village, and so forth.
And the proposition
is to be truly healthy
and to have predictably
good health going forward,
you have to have good
health on all three sides.
Take away any one of
these three things,
you jeopardize
somebody's health.
You could be a young man
with robust physical health
and great mental and
emotional clarity,
but if you live in
a war torn village,
that's why you need
all three sides.
So about 15 months ago, I'm
talking to-- now two years ago,
I'm talking to one of my
favorite entrepreneurs outside
of the technology industry,
but they're actually
a very technology
driven company.
Fred Smith, founder and CEO of
FedEx, now $50 billion in size.
There once was not a FedEx.
He started it from
raw scratch in 1971.
And I asked him what
accounts for FedEx
being successful
over the long term,
being able to
survive recessions,
global turmoil, new
competitors coming in,
big technology transitions.
And he made the
picture of a triangle,
and he said we are a
triangle of forces.
We have to be good at strategy,
execution, and culture.
I called execution the hard edge
simply because it's measurable.
The soft edge of
culture is beginning
to be measurable
thanks to Laszlo Bock,
thanks to companies like Google.
But we're way in the
early days of that.
And that's why people tend
to underinvest in that.
This is my favorite,
big data sports.
I have to tell this.
It takes about a minute.
It's how Jennie finch--
this is 10 years ago
in a demonstration during
spring training in Major League
Baseball.
The world's best
softball pitcher
struck out the two best
hitters in baseball
on three successive pitches.
They didn't each.
Neither of them got
even a foul ball.
And how did she do that?
Because it's amazing that when
you throw a softball 65 miles
an hour-- she can or could-- it
gets to the plate in about 4/10
of a second, which is the same
time it takes a Major League
Fastball, 95 miles an hour
thrown from a longer distance,
to get to the plate too.
So in theory, it
looks like it if it
takes the same amount
of time and there's
40% more surface
space on a softball,
it should be easier to hit.
Why is not easier to hit?
And the answer is It's
a big data problem.
Bonds and Pujols
could see everything.
A Major League Baseball
batter can get the bat
around in about 2/10s
of a second, which
means they have 2/10 of a second
to determine what the pitch is,
where it's going to go,
the speed of the pitch,
and so forth.
They could see it, but they
didn't know how to read it.
It was simply a big
data problem for them.
You've all heard of Malcolm
Gladwell's "10,000 Hours."
They had the 10,000
hours in baseball.
They could read a baseball.
They could read the
pattern that the yarn made.
pitcher's motion.
They didn't know what they were
looking at was Jennie Finch,
even though it was
right before their eyes.
Everybody talks about
corporate culture today.
Very few companies--
Google is one of the few
that really walks the talk.
And the reason it is so
very hard for companies--
and it may be even
challenging for Google.
You're a publicly
traded company.
You have to report
to Wall Street
four times a year-- is it
there's a built in bias
to fall back on measurable
and analytical things.
And particularly
because all of you
are so analytically gifted
and mathematically gifted,
it's your natural
default position anyway.
But I just want to make the case
that the cultural values side,
which increasingly is
getting measurable,
but it's not that
measurable today.
This is not a new
debate about the debate
between how much effort do you
put into corporate culture.
This is the guy
who invented what
was called scientific management
named Fredrick Taylor.
He took a stopwatch
and a clipboard
to factory floors
in the late 1800s.
First person to really take
advantage of his findings
was Henry Ford.
The Model T came out in 1908.
But it was 1913 when the
first assembly line was built,
and all of a sudden the
volume and the affordability
curve of Model T's just
got very, very attractive
to the point where Ford,
who paid his workers well,
could afford to buy the
car that they were making.
That had never been done.
By 1926, they're rolling
of the assembly line.
Ford is the dominant motor
car company in the world.
Then came the Great Depression.
Ford had labor problems.
People were complaining about
the dehumanizing factory floor.
See, Taylor had treated
people like machines.
You stood at the assembly line.
You did the same thing over
and over and over again
for 10 hours a day,
six days a week,
which was a typical
work week back then.
And Henry Ford didn't handle
the labor strikes very well.
And it really kind
of wrecked him.
You see, he couldn't understand,
during the Great Depression,
If he was paying people twice
the prevailing wage for factory
work, and the people were
employed to begin with,
because there was 25%
unemployment during the 1930s,
why his workers
were turning on him.
He went from being
this very creative guy
to this very bitter guy in
a very short period of time.
During the 1940s, he did not
distinguish himself very well
by being pro-Nazi,
and anti-Semitic,
and all kinds of bad things.
He just became a very,
very bitter angry guy,
because he couldn't
understand, fundamentally,
how he could have created
this great product
and these great jobs for people
and his workers turned on him.
Well, they turned on
him because they were
being treated like machines.
Along comes Alfred
Sloan, who was
able to copy the Ford--
he's the head of General
Motors-- able to copy the Ford
methodology on the factory
floor.
But he also had insight
into human nature, which
is both good for workplace
relationships at General Motors
and for his insights on
marketing segmentation.
Henry Ford liked to
say about the Model T,
you can have it any color you
want as long as it's black.
General Motors invented
market segmentation--
the Chevrolet, Pontiac,
The Oldsmobile, the Buick,
the Cadillac-- for different
parts of the market.
And so in the '30s, General
Motors went one way.
Ford went the other way.
Ford went on a roll.
That's the '53 Corvette.
And then it eventually succumbed
to the analytic financial
temptation.
It became by the 1970s
and '80s, a company that
was managed for the numbers.
It was managed for
shareholder profits.
the stock price.
And eventually led from
cars like the 1953 Corvette
to the 1986 Cadillac
Cimarron, which
makes everybody's list of
one of the worst cars ever,
because it was a Chevy.
See, the analytical people
and the finance people
who were managing the company
for shareholder profit
thought if you put a
Cadillac grill on a Chevrolet
and you called it a Cadillac and
charged twice as much for it,
man, will the numbers spike.
We're going to look so good.
Customers didn't
have the feedback.
There weren't things
like Facebook today where
people could carp about it.
And so it worked until
it stopped working.
Then when it stopped working,
it stopped working major time.
One of the fascinating ideas
to me-- and as you look around,
this is pretty easily confirmed
by your own observations-
Is do jerks win in
the marketplace?
Do you have to be a jerk to
run a great company today?
The company with a large
market value in the world,
the company that is sometimes
your friend and sometimes
your competitor, the great
man who started the company
and led its revival the second
time around, Steve Jobs,
was in many ways
brilliant but in many ways
was a class A jerk.
And he leaves us with this
uncomfortable question,
and that is, do you have
to be a jerk to succeed?
How many of you have read Elon
Musk's-- the biography on Elan
Musk by Ashley Vance?
It's a great book.
Brilliant man.
Works harder than
anybody, but he
has qualities that could
be described, academically,
in academic terms, as
being in A-hole many times.
And so the question is,
those people are successful.
Then when you look at the
other end of the spectrum,
I'm sure Google has some people
inside the organization that
are, out of 55,000
people, it's inevitable
that you'll have
people like that.
But on the whole, when
you look at Google
and how Google almost
always makes the top five
and I think more recently
in the last year,
the very top ranked company
in best places to work,
where you look at an analytics
company in North Carolina, SAS,
always makes to the top five
list of companies to work.
Great corporate campus,
all kinds of perks.
People are treated with
great respect at SAS.
And the question is,
why do both work?
Both models work.
You can win being
good people and you
can win being kind
of on the rough side.
And the answer is, it
goes to authenticity.
And the authenticity-- the
companies that get stuck
are the ones that can't decide
whether they're meritocracies
or sort of collective efforts.
And they toggle back and forth.
And that's where
the danger lies.
So the companies can be
harshly meritocratic.
Amazon's harshly meritocratic.
Elon Musk's companies
are harshly meritocratic.
I think Google was probably
more harshly meritocratic
in its early days.
And something that Laszlo Bock
talks about in his great book,
"Work Rules," but it has become
much broader and much more,
I think, inclusive and
respective of the individual.
Microsoft is harshly
meritocratic,
and it worked until
it stopped working.
And one of the things that
Satya Nadella, the new CEO
of Microsoft is
trying to do today
is to restore a more
collaborative culture
that Microsoft lost
under Steve Ballmer.
So what I wanted
to say is that this
is what a great
organization looks like.
They're great in strategy,
great in execution,
great in cultural
values, and particularly
the cultural values side.
But all three sides are
absolutely critical if you're
going to have the
conditions that
create teams of 2 to 12
people to spontaneously arise.
If you don't have the trust
factor, it isn't going to work.
Steve Jobs, I thought it would
be daring to mention Steve Jobs
and hold him up at
a Google meeting.
But here I am.
I'm stuck now.
He's often held up as this
great, solo, maverick, iconic
entrepreneur.
People mistakenly think that he
started the Macintosh project.
He didn't start the
Macintosh project.
That he invented the iPod,
the iPhone, and so forth.
He didn't.
In fact, the unrecognized
genius of Steve Jobs
was his ability to
pair up with people
who were his complementary,
his opposite in temperament
and skill, who made him whole.
Steve Wozniak in the
beginning, his worst failure
was that because of a bad
pairing with John Sculley,
he got his mojo back when he
paired with the Pixar people.
And that really taught Steve
how to become a better manager.
When he came back the
second time at Apple,
he was a superb manager.
And he always liked to say-- and
he said this in a "60 Minutes"
interview in the last years of
this life-- where his business
philosophy came from.
Because he was
not a good leader.
He was a really charismatic
visionary his first time
around at Apple, but he
was not the great CEO
that we know of until it
was the second time around.
Where did you get that idea?
What was your
fundamental teaching?
You didn't finish college.
You didn't take
management courses.
And here's what he
told "60 Minutes."
"My model for business
is The Beatles.
They were four guys that
kept each other's negative
tendencies in check.
They balanced each other,
and the total was greater
than the sum of the parts.
Great things in business are
never done by one person.
They're done by a
team of people."
So that's where I
want to end and would
happy to take questions for
the remainder of your time.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Going back to the
beginning of your claim about
teams of 4 to 9 people
or 7 plus or minus 2,
you made an argument for why
that's the right team size,
n (n - 1) /2, I think?
RICHARD KARLGAARD: Yeah, 7 plus
or minus 2 is a good range.
AUDIENCE: Now, why are you
advocating for spontaneous team
formation, more informal
teams, which you also said,
but I don't think you really
gave any particular reasons
why we would prefer
that as opposed to more
top-down management deciding
which projects would be on
and trying to assign individuals
with complementary skillsets
to different teams
as appropriate.
RICHARD KARLGAARD:
In the book, we
go into this quite a bit in
the beginning of the book.
And it's a great question, which
is why we put it up upfront.
And that's the importance
of maneuverability
in today's economy.
Not just speed, but
maneuverability.
Speed can apply
that you're really
good going straight
ahead with a plan
and executing it like crazy.
Maneuverability is
what happens when
some new disruptor or
some new competitor
comes into your field, or
regulation changes, or laws
change, or whatever that is.
Sometimes, the
maneuverability means
you have to go sideways
or even backwards.
And our contention is-- I
use the example of Lenovo.
Lenovo, I was having dinner
with one of their executives.
Lenovo is $40 billion in size.
Lenovo is the Chinese company
that bought the IBM PC
division about 10 years ago.
And they're a
pretty good company.
A lot of their North
American operations
are based in
Raleigh-Durham area.
Not a lot of people know that.
But they're a great company.
They hit on all cylinders.
I guess, if Elon Musk
changes the world,
then we're going
to have to come up
with a new metaphor
than cylinders.
And this marketing,
the CMO of Lenovo
was talking about Xiaomi,
the Chinese company that
makes smartphones.
It's X-I-A-O-M-I, I believe
and how fast Xiaomi was moving,
and that Lenovo couldn't figure
out a way to move as fast
as Xiaomi.
And I said, well, look.
They're coming into
this marketplace.
They're new.
Do you have a class
Innovator's Dilemma problem?
Is that your problem?
And the Innovator's
Dilemma problem
is that when you're an incumbent
and a new company comes
in with a faster
moving technology that
is following the price curve
down and offering products
at a much lower price,
the Innovator's Dilemma
is what do you do?
Do you want to get into a
price war with guerrillas?
Rebel kind of guerrillas.
And that wasn't the problem.
The problem was pure speed.
He said Xiaomi was opening up
new markets in Chinese cities.
They're primarily in China
and elsewhere in Asia.
That's why a lot of
Americans know of them.
But they were just opening
up new marketplaces
faster than Lenovo could
even talk about it.
Lenovo would have
these meetings,
how are we going to counter
Xiaomi in this city,
or that city, or that country?
And they simply-- while
they were talking about it,
they would blink and
Xiaomi had already done it.
And so that, to me,
that was a wake up
call that in this
economy, you have
to have almost this immune
response, that organizations
almost have to be
considered alive,
and you have to have
this immune response.
And the spontaneity is
a vital part of that.
Is Google going to leave its
strategy in mobile entirely up
to spontaneous teams?
That's not what
I'm talking about.
I mean, I think there are these
big strategic initiatives,
and some projects
are always going
to call for large
numbers of people.
But on the day to
day battles, when
you see a problem or you see
an opportunity, if all of those
have to be discussed
and planned,
then you just put gunk
inside the organization
and can't move fast enough.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So
[INAUDIBLE] do you have
any recommendations for
organizational policies
or programs or
operating models for how
to enable that to happen
[INAUDIBLE] that already
has that pyramidal structure?
RICHARD KARLGAARD: Yeah,
there's an interesting model
of Infosys.
Cloud computing
is the real threat
to the Indian
outsourcing IT model.
And so what do you do?
Infosys is now being
led by a guy who was
the number two in R&D at SAP.
And his thought is that
Infosys has to go up market.
They're just going to get
automated out of existence.
The cloud is going
to take them out.
Automation will take them out.
They have to go higher
added value work.
How do you do that?
Because they were really
set up as this kind
of IT factory model.
Throw as many bodies
against a problem
and get it done as you
could, and do it at a cost
that American IT
companies couldn't match.
And so what he's
doing now is something
that was a project that
was initiated at SAP.
I don't know if it's being
followed now in his absence.
SAP has 60,000 employees,
20,000 developers.
And that is to atomize
the developer teams
into units of about 10 to
12 people without bosses.
It's a radical idea.
Or the bosses have a
very limited amount
of time they're allowed to check
in on the progress of the team.
So these self-governing
teams is something
that SAP is experimenting with.
It's worth watching,
and it's worth
watching to see how Infosys
is going to do the same thing.
AUDIENCE: Where do
organizations go wrong?
RICHARD KARLGAARD: Organizations
go wrong in multiple ways.
They go wrong when they are
fixated with their stock price
and shareholder return.
This is what got
Ginni Rometty at IBM.
The previous CEO of IBM, a guy
named Sam Palmisano, on his way
out really stuck her
with a big problem
that she was too slow to see.
And the problem was he had
promised Wall Street IBM's
in such good shape
we're going to have
five years in a row
of earnings growth.
Now the problem was is
that IBM's revenue was flat
and even slightly down.
So what do you do if
you've promised Wall Street
that you're going to have five
years in a row of earnings
growth, but your
revenue is down?
You have to steal
it from somewhere.
You have to steal it out
of R&D. And where IBM stole
it was from the crown
jewel, by all appearances
and all reporting.
And that is their
global services,
which is 2/3 of their $90
billion a year revenue.
And so the service quality
of IBM service clients
was rapidly going downhill,
thus opening up the door
for Tata, Infosys, even Dell
creeping into the service
business in a way.
And finally she saw
what was going on,
and she called a halt to
it and told Wall Street
that it was a bad decision.
We're not going to
stick to that decision,
because we're eating
our seed corn.
We're starving our R&D,
and we're not adequately
staffing our service
organization.
So that's one way.
Another way is, as I said
in the book, companies
that toggle back and forth
and never quite figure out
what they are, who they
are, whether they're
a meritocracy,
where they're more
of a collaborative environment.
The CEO wakes up from
one day to another
and can't decide
whether he's going
to be tough in the manner
of Jeff Bezos, or Steve
Jobs, or Elon Musk,
or more nurturing
in the manner of others,
and goes back and forth,
leaves people confused.
Executive hypocrisy is
the surest, quickest way
to kill the culture
of an organization
and wreck the organization.
That's when the executive
is asking things
that he or she would not do
personally-- not work as hard,
not to abide by travel expense
limitations, and so forth.
That's a killer.
I once remember
I spent five days
on the road with Bill
Gates in the early '90s
when he was at the
peak of his game.
And I said, why are we flying
around in coach, by the way?
Because this is a
multi-city tour.
And Bill Gates, even
then, it was '93.
Bill Gates, even then, was
worth $6 or $8 billion.
And he said, if I don't
do it, nobody will do it.
And so we fly coach.
You can upgrade on
your own nickel.
We stay at Hilton level hotels.
If you want to stay at
a more expensive hotel,
do it on your own nickel.
And we rent Ford Taurus or
Toyota Camry level cars.
If you want to have more,
you do it on your own nickel.
So I have this
wonderful picture where
he's sitting in row 27 in a
late night flight from Boston
to LaGuardia, working on
his Compaq 496 laptop.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I have
[INAUDIBLE] in New York,
and they're doing
some great work.
They're really innovative,
and that trust is there.
And they're doing
some fantastic work.
Our counterparts in Sunnyvale,
head office is looking to us
and they're like,
how is this possible?
What are you doing?
How are we able to feed
that back and learn
to manage at the scale
that they're dealing with?
RICHARD KARLGAARD: I don't know.
Lana was telling me coming in
that Google had been engaged
in three years of research on
team efficacy, and dynamics,
and trust, and all
of those things.
I'll be really eager
to see the research.
I can tell you that the
primary motivation is this.
Execution is so
important in a company--
doing things faster, cheaper,
using data and analytics,
optimizing your supply
chain, being efficient
with your use of capital.
All of those are in
the camp of what you
call continual marginal gains.
They're measurable.
You're always trying to improve
them-- always, always, always.
The side of corporate
culture, particularly trust,
is the side of
transformational gains.
Now, what percentage of
people's brain power,
and efforts, and passions do you
think the average Googler puts
into their job?
It's not 100%.
Nobody puts in 100%.
Maybe a founder of a
company puts in 100%.
But for most of us, it's 50,
60, 70-- something like that.
What if you could move the
average commitment and passion
of people from just
10 percentage points,
if you could get somebody from
60 to 70 multiplied by 55,000?
The only way that
people are going
to do that, that are not the
founders, that don't have stock
options that are
going to make them
a billionaire, that
are working hard,
that are working for a fair
salary but not a particularly
great salary?
The only way that people
are going to do that
is if they fundamentally trust
the organization and the people
who lead the organization.
And they fundamentally
trust it in an ethical way,
that this company is
doing the right thing.
This is something where I
can put my big passions into
and I will not regret it.
And that is huge.
And it's so underestimated.
Is that my phone?
It's talked about a lot
inside of organizations,
but rarely do
organizations do it.
When I was reading Laszlo
Bock's book "Work Rules."
Geez.
You'd think I'd have a limit
on the number of rings.
It's going to-- there you go.
I think that he's really
on to that in a big way.
And I think where Google
has the opportunity
is to be the leading company
to come up with analytics
that support that.
We have science and data
on individuals going back
to Myers-Briggs and
everything that has followed.
We have HR IT companies like
Workday, Success Factors, which
was bought by SAP, and others.
I have not yet seen the
highly analytical approach
to what is it that
creates teams.
We know the science.
The science that you can
get from anthropology,
neuroscience, and
so on and so forth,
into which we go into
great detail in the book.
But the data is still emergent.
And I think that companies
like Google that figure that
out and figure out how
you quantify trust,
and can you watch
trust go up and down,
and what are the things you
can do to facilitate it?
What impact does it have
on individuals and teams?
It's going to be huge.
Somebody's going to create
the Salesforce of that.
You're either going to do
it internally at Google
and spin it out, or
somebody will do it.
I think we're on the
verge of that happening.
Time for one more.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How would
you get Wall Street
investors to get on board with
understanding [INAUDIBLE]?
RICHARD KARLGAARD: Well,
that's a great question.
How do you get Wall Street-- if
quarterly reports and managing
for shareholder profitability
can be poison to a company,
as it was for General
Motors, as it was for IBM
and many, many others-- Dell.
You can go private.
That helps.
Dell has done that.
You can have a different
kind of ownership and voting
structures.
Google has.
I think that was a
stroke of genius.
It certainly hasn't hurt
Google's market cap.
I think that founders, founder
CEOs have a really powerful
advantage in the marketplace
here in that they can tell Wall
Street to go stuff it in a way
that a hired gun CEO can't.
I once talked to a
CEO about this problem
who wasn't a founder.
And I said, how do you do this?
He said you sandbag.
He said I have to
lie to the street.
He said, if I think we can
have 12% growth this year
and 15% profit growth,
I'm certainly not going
to tell that to the street.
I'm going to tell them
maybe 2/3 of that,
and I'm going to take
that money and make sure
that we're continually investing
in the culture of this company.
So some hired gun
CEOs can do that.
Alan Mulally did that at Ford.
But Alan Mulally was one of
those rare CEOs who is not
a founder, who exuded
this kind of moral quality
and ethical quality
that people got behind.
There's this great story
when he came into Ford.
And Ford was losing
money, and he was meeting
with his direct reports.
And they had yellow,
red, and green cards.
And they were supposed
to hold up the cards
to signal how their
own divisions were
doing inside the company.
And everybody held up green.
And he just-- he had a meltdown.
A useful meltdown, in
fact, with colorful words
emanating out of his mouth.
How in the heck can you be
all showing green cards when
this company is losing money?
He says, from now on, we
speak the truth around here,
and I'm not going to fire you.
At least the first time if you
tell me you have a problem.
And the first person to do that
was a guy named Mark Fields.
He said, OK.
Things really suck for us.
Here's why.
Here's the kind of help I
need in the organization.
And today, Mark
Fields is the CEO.
So I think when an
outsider CEO comes in,
they have to very early
set that tone of honesty
and accountability,
and do it in a way
where people are
held accountable
but they're not shot
for being honest.
That will wreck
companies very fast
if you're the opposite of that.
We're at the end of our time.
I want to thank you for
coming, for your attention.
There are aggressively priced
books in the back for $10.
If you're Amazon Prime,
it'll cost you $15.
If you're not Prime, it'll
cost you more than that.
And at the bookstore,
it'll cost you $30.
So if you want, they're there.
And it's really a thrill
to be here and see.
This is my first time
at the New York office.
I've been in the Mountain
View office complex and campus
many times.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]